hi everyone i'm annie john baptiste and
i lead product inclusion at google
product inclusion is all about bringing
an inclusive lens throughout the product
design process and I'm excited to share
a little bit about how we've been doing
that first I just want to welcome you to
the session this may be a newer concept
for you and so I hope that it's helpful
but I'm super excited that you're
spending the time to learn about product
inclusion today before we get started I
just wanted to level-set and have a
shared framework around what we mean
when we say product inclusion product
inclusion is about building designing
coding for everyone so no matter who you
are where you live what you look like we
want to make sure that you feel thought
of in the entire product design process
and when you pick up a product or
service and so at Google we want to make
sure that we're bringing that inclusive
lens throughout everything that we
create so the first thing that's really
important to think about is really how
this ties back into Google's mission and
so we talked about organizing the
world's information and making it
universally accessible and useful it's
really the universal peace that we're
leaning into in product inclusion and we
say not just for some for everyone right
so I talked a little bit about some
dimensions that we think of but it's
really important to make sure that
everyone is thought of in the process
and especially those who have been
historically underrepresented in the
product design process now this work
builds on a lot of great work namely
accessibility work and next billion
users work what happens with product
inclusion is that we actually look at 12
dimensions of diversity and the
intersections of those dimensions what I
mean when I say the intersections of the
dimensions is that users aren't in a
silo
right they don't have one thing that
makes them who they are and so it's
really important to think about
everything holistically when you're
building products or services using
myself as an example I'm a black woman
I'm also left-handed I'm not black on
Monday a woman on Tuesday and
left-handed on Wednesday all of those
things are encompassed within me affect
how I move through the world and
definitely affect how I use product
and so we want to make sure that we're
thinking holistically about all of those
dimensions on when we're building so on
this slide you're seeing a few of the
dimensions that we look at again we look
at 12 but things like gender age ability
education socioeconomic status and more
are really integral in to making sure
that you're asking who else and really
broadening who your users could and
should be it's also really important to
note that there's a lot of untapped
opportunity when you bring an inclusive
lens and really Center those who have
been historically underrepresented so
what you're seeing on this slide are a
bunch of statistics around things like
purchasing power digital usage for a lot
of the historically underrepresented
groups that we focus on with product
inclusion so you can see stats as it
relates to accessibility right there 1
billion people in the world with a
disability for example or you can look
at 700 million users coming online in
the next few years it's really exciting
that there's so much opportunity when
you bring in inclusive lens and that can
really affect your business and being
able to serve even more users it's
important to note that product inclusion
is not just a one point in your process
it's really throughout the process and
the earlier that you bring it in the
better so you can bring it in an
ideation for example when you're
starting to think of a product or
service that may have an untapped
opportunity but what's really important
is to highlight and understand what key
points in the process you're going to
kind of bring that inclusive lens we
call those inflection points and on this
slide you can see there are multiple
inflection points where we've started to
bring that inclusive lens throughout the
process and the goal is that the end
result is more inclusive more people so
next I'm just going to jump into a few
case studies to help you understand what
our product in gee inclusion journey
looks like and how this can actually be
put into action so this first video is
from a team that worked on camera
sensors and what they wanted to do was
really ensure that they brought this
inclusive lens and ensured all skin
tones were accurately represented what I
love about this is that it shows that no
matter where you are in the organization
should you have a part to play in
building for everyone and with everyone
so with that we'll roll the video
pictures tell stories it doesn't really
matter if it's a selfie or if it's a
portrait that somebody is taking of
another person you are sharing in that
human moment let's take a picture you
too
one two three oh he's too dark so this
is where the discussion started if you
just use my phone it's got a better
sensor
better sensor what does that even mean
color tuning is an extremely complicated
process when we look at images when we
try to do is figure out how much of a
difference there is between let's say a
reference image and the image that we
actually are trying to quantify we were
running some tests on a product and it
was the proximity sensor we were testing
and we said oh it looks like it does 60
centimeters and we look to each other
and go we're both white the technology
itself as many people will say is not
racist it's just that it wasn't tested
properly to make sure that the designers
weren't unconsciously biased hey there's
an entire world out there and we want to
make sure this works for everybody I
love the fact that we get to influence
cameras that we get to share those
experiences of life and emotion to me
that is what imaging is about it is a
vehicle to express humanity I take a
picture of you two
one two three the next case study I'd
like to show you is with duo low light
mode what the duo low like team did was
and be intentional about bringing
diverse perspectives to the table from
the beginning of their process at Google
we have what we call inclusion champions
who are Googlers from across the globe
in multiple dimensions of diversity who
have helped us dog food or user test our
products so the duo low light mode team
knew that they wanted to make sure that
no matter where you are in the world or
if you had certain lighting or you had
light or dark skin tones you are going
to be accurately represented when using
this video product and so they worked
with our inclusion champions to make
sure that we tested across multiple
dimensions of diversity to make sure
that again everyone feels beautifully
and accurately represented and thought
of when they use the product now I'll go
into a little bit of the research that
we've been doing over the past year on
the business case for inclusion I hope
it's helpful to start to frame what
users and
they're thinking about as lates to
products inclusion but also how you can
start to implement it in your everyday
work so the first piece of data that I
want to share with you all is that there
are four places in the product design
process where it's really important to
bring that inclusive lens those four
points are the ideation user research
user testing and marketing phases now a
few slides back I showed you an
end-to-end product inclusion process
slide where you saw multiple inflection
points or points in the process where
you could bring product inclusions into
the fold that being said when we did
research and looked at a bunch of
different teams across Google what we
found was that these are the four points
where teams constantly came back to and
also these were the four points where if
you did bring an inclusive lens were
intentional about doing so you actually
disproportionately created a more
inclusive product and so would encourage
you all to think about if these four
points in the process make sense for
your organization and how you can bring
that inclusive lens to those four points
it's also important to just start to ask
who else so for example if you're
starting to id8 within your organization
maybe bring someone from another piece
of the organization or another team into
the brainstorming because they'll likely
have different perspectives if you're
already doing user research maybe you do
user research internationally or with a
different demographic than you usually
do right these small changes can lead to
really big results as it relates to
bringing with that inclusive lens the
second piece was that a hundred percent
of teams that brought an inclusive lens
into their process did so at at least
two of the four touch points I just
mentioned right so either the ideation
user research user testing or marketing
phases they did at least two so it may
be the ideation and marketing or the
user research and user testing but they
made sure that it wasn't just an
isolated point in time but that they
were doing it throughout the process and
I think that that's really important not
only because you're starting to think
holistically about your process but also
you can involve different team members
and different organization members who
have different expertise to again start
to bring more perspectives that have
historically been underrepresented into
the fold
another key finding was that both
underrepresented and majority groups
prefer inclusive marketing and product
design what does that mean it's been a
notion that only underrepresented groups
want to see themselves reflected and
what we found is that that's actually
not true right everyone or the majority
of people want to see diversity and
inclusion both in marketing and
storytelling but also in product design
and so I think that that's a big shift
that we want to make sure that we think
about it's not just those are who have
been historically underrepresented but
it's actually underrepresented and
majority consumers or users the last
finding that I'd like to share with you
all is that teams no matter their
representation that were intentional
about bringing an inclusive lens were
able to do so right so regardless of the
team makeup and we talked a lot about
you know the systemic changes that need
to happen in order to have
representation and inclusive culture
that is incredibly important still but
even as you're working to get to that
representation you can start to work on
product inclusion now right so
regardless of the makeup if you're
setting standards if you're holding
yourself and your team accountable you
can actually start to make headway in
building that inclusive product so now
I'm just going to go through three
principles that we help to guide teams
along their product inclusion journey
the first one is to address the user so
I showed you two a few of the twelve
dimensions that we focus on as it
relates to product inclusion but really
thinking about what dimensions have been
underrepresented in your process and
bringing those into the fold you want to
address the users again asking who else
and continuing to expand the pool of who
users could and should be the second one
is to start with equity so inclusion
shouldn't be an afterthought it's not
something that comes in after you've
actually created everything right how
can you bring it in earlier on in the
process and at multiple points in the
process again this doesn't sit within
one team it sits within all parts of the
organization and so how are you making
sure that you found those key process
points and you brought the key
stakeholders in to kind of help move
that along
and the last one is to continually test
so just like any other part of your
product design process this needs to be
iterative you want to make sure that you
aren't just checking a box but you're
constantly shifting you're constantly
improving you're constantly getting
feedback just like any other part of
your product design process you want to
make sure that you're learning you're
growing and you're bringing more voices
into the fold and you're adapting as
you're getting feedback right so this
just like any other part of your process
you want to commit to you want to have
standards and accountability frameworks
for and you want to constantly
constantly be improving and so with that
thank you so much for joining the
product inclusion session I hope it was
helpful
and have a great day thanks so much